république république démocratie justice
liberté laïcité travail responsabilité
diversité autorités or nos efforts
république républicain j'ai pensé que ce
qui nous rassemble est c'est l'idée que
nous nous faisons de la république
l'idéal républicain c'est l'identité de
la france la république c'est la liberté
c'est le mérite c'est l'autorité mais
c'est avant tout l'unité
je veux une formation politique avec des
adhérents qui participent avec des
adhérents qui se sentent concernés qui
sont du patisseau une nouvelle force
politique qui rassemblera des femmes et
des hommes qui comme vous comme nous
veulent préparer l'alternance de façon
efficace le parti démocratique où vous
pourrez voter
on vous écoutera parti qui fait
confiance à ses adhérents le
rassemblement pour retrouver de
l'espérance c'est un projet c'est une
vision pour l'avenir de la france c'est
la france dans toute sa diversité
quel que soit son âge son sexe ses
origines et ses idéaux c'est la croyance
dans le progrès le travail justement
récompensés c'est la volonté de ne pas
céder c'est le refus du misérabilisme de
la médiocrité et de l'échec
c'est une famille ouverte l'alliance de
droite républicaine et du centre
c'est relever les défis du 21e siècle il
est venu le temps de passer de la
promesse ou zac
vous qui croyez en l'autorité le progrès
le travail la responsabilité la liberté
rejoignez nous l'alternance est en
marche
l'alternance est en marche et rien ne
l'arrêtera rien ne l'arrêtera
l'alternance est en marche
rien absolument rien ne l'arrêtera
m